we are very excited about our next guest
she is five-time grammy winner did you
hear that five times
grammy winner faith hill she is one of
the country music's most successful
artists thank you very much hill is also
a talented actress and she stars in the
mega hit yellowstone prequel 1883 and
she's knockout in it she and her husband
that would be tim mcgraw play james and
margaret dutton they are the great
grandparents of john dutton of
yellowstone who was portrayed by kevin
costner you know that so in 1883 it
follows a dutton family's dangerous
journey west across the plains to a
better life in this clip margaret talks
to her daughter elsa while they're in a
river about why there's no such thing as
freedom
[Music]
i don't know what life is like in oregon
but there'll be rules there too
[Music]
this
trail is as free as you'll ever be
the only rules you need to follow
are the ones in your heart
yeah 1883 is on the viacom cbs streaming
service paramount plus first on cbs
mornings guess who's here in the studio
faith hill
we've been waiting for you all day faith
thank you so let's talk about 1883
because number one
you play a real gritty girl and you like
being a gritty girl it seems oh yes i'm
a greedy girl i'm from mississippi so
no i grew up in the dirt no no because i
literally you're driving a wagon in this
series and she says to me have you ever
driven a wagon i go look at me faith
wagon
wagon yeah g wagon
very well played very true okay and then
i asked you i said why don't we go on a
road trip in a wagon yes i would like
that movie music i would like to go with
you in a wagon that'd be amazing but you
were saying this is the hardest thing
that you guys have done how come
oh wow uh
physically the
the hardest thing we've done and for tim
to say that for those of you who know
tim my my husband he is uh physically
he's in shape and he can handle
everything as are you
yeah
well yeah thank you but unlike him
for him to say that
the most physically challenging thing
that he's ever done me as well mentally
as well it was just i mean to be
real and authentic in that time period
um
taylor one taylor sheridan uh wanted us
to really dive in
do a deep dive and
just be it live it and we did it's your
first time together too as husband and
wife yeah what was the conversation
leading up to should we do it should we
not were you nervous about doing it
um
we
we really didn't question doing it after
we read the script because
it was
so remarkable and is so remarkable uh
it was just the fact that we had the
time to do it which is also rare that we
were both available can you find it the
stars lined up
and it was just a chance an opportunity
we couldn't pass out do you think it
helped or hurt being a real-life married
couple playing this couple
um
i think
that uh
it it it was a benefit to us as well um
for sure i think someone who
could have done in i mean
it was a benefit i'm sure yeah i mean we
use it as a benefit we've been married
for 25 years the thing that we chose to
do is uh we decided not to
rehearse together why is that ever well
because
we're together all the time we have
three daughters been married for 25
years
we thought okay
the spontaneity is going to be created
and
the moment that we you know set foot on
set
and and
tim is james and and i'm margaret and
that's who we are and let's that's where
we we become them is on that set and not
at home this couple is literally
fighting to survive
do you find any parallels not just with
your character but maybe your marriage
fighting to survive
no i haven't thought about that i hope
not no i mean just the the characters
individually do you find any parallels
between who you play and who your
husband plays well i think as a parent
as a
for everyone that's on the show with you
know immigrants
all of us um all the actors we're
fighting to survive yeah and i think the
the thing that is um
a reminder is when you
have a family and you take them you have
a dream and you take them someplace that
you really have no you've never been you
can't just dial it up on the computer
yeah and say oh we want to go there that
looks amazing yeah we have this picture
of you i'm sorry oh no go ahead what i
was gonna say like we have this picture
of you driving the wagon as gail said at
the top you actually had to learn how to
do that and oh yeah and i'm curious do
you think 1883 is on the one hand a long
time ago but also not a long time ago
right so that's right do you think you
could have made that kind of journey
once upon a time
um i have yes you can i could have yeah
i mean i i pray i could have but i tell
you what it it pushes the limits of your
character of the things that you think
that are impossible that you would never
be able to do or pull off
or survive you i mean you do yeah yeah
because it is truly about and you're a
mississippi girl yes as tough as they
come yeah right
can i talk about you and rita wilson
that's a funny thing but you and
you and rita get to act together and
you're very good friends yes what was
that like faith because it was fun to
see the two of you on the screen you
were you were drinking whiskey punch
and it looked like both of you gotten a
little tipsy but it was so fun to watch
the two of you together
it was um i think we had the best the
best time honestly i i went to the
director and i said i am so excited i
can't tell you
this is going to be the best day of
filming ever
but i just want to warn you that
i don't know if we're going to get
anything because we're going to laugh
the entire time that's all we do when
we're together yeah i mean obviously we
have a deep relationship but um
we had a good time what do you like
about playing margaret though what do
you like about her she's a very strong
character and it's fun to watch you
embody her too to me oh thank you i mean
that um i she's just
she's
she's
strong you know she's strong but she's
also dealing with a lot of things as
many people and women did during that
time and and to this day you're you have
a you know my husband is a dreamer and i
want to believe in him and i also want
to
i want my children to know that
i i trust what your dad is doing right
and and we are going to follow him then
we have
an amazing
daughter um isabelle may played by
isabelle may he was an incredible actor
and audi who is our young son
uh you know you're trying to he's young
isabel is just a what she she just goes
wild and free yeah well it's great to
see the two of you together on screen
and little known fact faith hill and tim
mcgraw actually like to do road trips
that's sweet driving their own suv
dropping their own gas that's pumping
their own gas that's right that's a
surprise at a gas station near you faith
hill thank you thank you thank you
gorgeous continued success great show
thank you you can see more of faith hill
tonight oh you're on the stephen colbert
tonight oh yes yeah right here on cbs
and
i didn't know that and you can watch new
episodes of 1883 every sunday on
paramount plus